okay wait how do i rotate
wait
[Music]
okay
i'm just gonna be
reading
and showing you guys what i have so far
hold on though
ellie stop licking my leg
gotta chill
okay
all right so i'm going to start the
video
by saying my experience going to a
pickup boot camp
so i'm going to say this how it's going
to go
i went to i went to a pickup artist boot
camp i know what you're thinking and
also if you guys have any notes of like
what i should change or like questions
you have let me just swipe off the
camera
um let me know hi
but you guys are getting like an early
sneak peek because i think this is going
to be a really big video it's just
taking me time
okay so i went to a pickup artist boot
camp i know what you're thinking what is
a pickup pickup artist boot camp and why
on earth were you there to answer the
question let's start with pick up
artistry and where did it come from in
simple terms a pickup artist is a person
um according
in recording i'm gonna say according to
google
according
to google according to google a pickup
artist is a person who is skilled at
striking up conversations
in order to attract a potential sexual
partner um this became very much
mainstream with the release of the game
by neil strauss but even before then
there were
um coaches i'm gonna say but even
but even before then
there were coaches
or pickup coaches or pickup
coaches like
um like real social dynamics and i was
trying to think of another one that was
older and i don't have anyone there yet
but i'll add one
um okay so that's going to be like the
first part of the video so the next part
of the video is said now why did i want
to go over the last couple of months i
have been watching manosphere and men's
self-help content this includes kevin
samuel's fresh and fit roll of tamasi
and mediocre tutorials and reviews i'll
say we're in some others i might just
put some others and some other
um
um and then should i i should probably
do like a brief definition
um
because it's like how would you define
the red pill
that's an interesting question because
if i google red pill like
it's not a very good definition um i
think
like it's basically just saying it's
sexist um
uh okay over the last couple months i've
been watching manosphere content
um
this content has
given me
a little bit of insight a bit of insight
into
into how hard
dating is for men
um but and i'll say but the red pill has
mixed
beliefs about pickups some say it's a
waste of time some guys say that they
got some guys say that pickup artists
are creeps and some say that it's useful
so i decided to go find out because i'm
nosy
and that's
what do you guys think that like how
does that sound give me like feedback
okay so then
i'm gonna go into the first step was
finding a pickup artist that seemed
credible um i had john anthony lifestyle
on my channel to talk about dating
advice for men a couple months back i've
heard mixed things about him in the
community but you cannot deny that the
man seems like he knows how to get hot
girls he lives with three brazilian
smoke smoke shows claims you have slept
with over a thousand women and has more
proof of these encounters than anyone
else i have seen in the industry it
seems like the man knows how to get laid
um the second reason i picked him is
because
he
most of his system that i'd heard him
talk about just made sense to me he
compares talking to girls a lot to sales
and i worked in sales so a lot of the
analogies made sense
um so
and i worked in sales
so a lot of the analogies
made sense
um
okay so then
the next thing i had to do and do you
guys like the backstory of like like in
the video do you think that i should
have more of like the backstory of
like how i found that camp um
why i picked his
like why i picked that one
and all of that or do you think maybe
leave that out let me know
um okay so my initial goal was to invite
a guy that had little to no experience
with women and document his progress
throughout the boot camp
um
and come back and let my followers know
how it went but i had trouble finding a
guy that was wildly unsuccessful with
women and also wanted to go
randomly i met a guy when i was visiting
a friend randomly i met
a guy
through mutual friends
who was familiar with pickup
familiar with pickup
and said he would be
interested in going
period
okay
that's like pretty much how far i've
gotten
so that you would be interested in going
you'd be surprised how much work a lot
of these like
videos take to like script out
especially this one because
there's just so many like angles of how
i could do it
light is not doing i'm gonna move you
guys back over here
okay
ten thousand views in an hour
where is my boyfriend at he's in the u.s
i'm in england
sad
huh
hold on one second
she's
okay sorry
um
is that cheating if you're in different
countries yeah
it's kind of a stupid question to be
honest
um
okay
hold on one
thank
second
[Music]
okay
okay i'm sorry okay
um
okay
so my initial goal was to invite a guy
that had little to no experience with
women and document his progress
throughout the boot camp
um
but i sleep but
i had trouble finding a guy that was
wildly unsuccessful with women and
actually wanted to go randomly i met a
guy through mutual friends who was
familiar with pickup and said he was
interested in going
um he was
he was
however
he was
pretty experienced with pick up
women and pick up
and pick up but still interested
and learning
more period
okay so the first night we all met up in
this hotel room before going out
for the night i was a little nervous
because i felt like the guys were going
to be really awkward or weird
or just uncomfortable because i was the
only girl
um
or just uncomfortable hopefully soon
i love rebecca she's great
um so then and the hotel we met up
before going out
um the first thing i noticed was
a lot of what they taught was confidence
and having the confidence to go up to
women
and talk to them
we would go up to a nightclub or a bar
and the guys would approach women with
the coaches and
approach women and the coaches would
give them feedback for example one piece
of advice that they give is to break the
touch barrier you can't show a girl that
you're confident in your own body if
you're too afraid to touch her another
example of something they taught is
is not
is
is
to ask for the kiss
to ask for
oh my gosh
so
uh
did our team win the last game yes we
killed them
okay
and the guys would approach women and
the coaches would give them feedback an
example of feedback that is given is not
to seem too friendly and befriend and
placed in the friend zone ask for the
kiss
um
okay so the day two i was absolutely
tired super exhausted um
because we stayed out
until four am
we went to a mall they would approach
girls there
and they would approach girls there um
it was actually kind of fun i would pick
up a girl for them to go after and
they would send a group of guys
to talk to them
um another thing i noticed was that it
does not so much matter what the girl
looked like i'm sure they appreciated if
they were hotter but
um they really
would
approach
damn near anybody
um
there were times where i
there were times where
i went in
to talk to the girl
and make her feel more comfortable
more comfortable
um
[Music]
what else would you guys want to know
about this
um
so are they manipulating women so i'm
i'm writing my video about the pickup
event that i went to so like the pickup
boot camp
i did not think any of the stuff they
taught was manipulation most of the
stuff that i saw was teaching guys to be
confident um
it reminded me a lot of sales a lot of
times they were teaching how to make
women feel more comfortable
the guys were a lot more normal than you
would think there's one or two that were
pretty odd but like for the most part
they're like pretty normal
um
what i learned about players um
most of those guys
of those guys do want
do want to settle down at some point
at some point
with surprise with
and all of them
said they wanted
a girl with a lower
low body count
um some of them stay off social media
specifically
to avoid girls finding each other
um and a lot of them talk about a lot of
them
will use you as practice
do i think it was helpful or really or
is it something you can do yourself i
think a lot of these guys at least
conferences look at these as a hail mary
to change everything i think
realistically you can maybe get 10
better in a weekend um i think it's good
for a beginner um but not as helpful for
um
but not as helpful for someone just
starting out most people
won't actually do that criticisms um
sometimes the instructors would go home
with different girls so if i paid that
much money and like you're going home
with a girl like halfway through the
night i personally would be mad and like
plus that's like another girl that could
have been going home with one of the
guys um
what did i learn from the conference
getting um laid is a lot harder for guys
than i thought
even the relatively attractive guys had
to approach a lot of girls
um
before they found one
they found one
to go home with them
i don't promote that type of lifestyle
but i think the skills that
um can help guys that actually want to
get a girl get in the door
i don't promote pickup i don't promote
sleeping with a bunch of girls treating
girls like objects
but i do think that some of the skills
that
are taught can be helpful when you want
to find a girlfriend or a wife
and do i think women need game
that is probably a different video
hmm
okay i think i need to go through this
footage it's my next thing i need to do
that i have the rough
outline okay guys i'm gonna talk to you
later